réveillonner pas non simplement
entretenir entre nous un réveillon en
toute simplicité
le soir du 31 décembre il ya ceux qui
aiment faire la fête ou dîner entre amis
et puis il ya ceux pour qui la saint
sylvestre est une soirée comme une autre
un dîner tranquille en couple ou bien
même seul et après le dessert vite au
lit je couchais ce que je fais son
travail a fait la semaine alors le reste
du temps la fatigue après une grosse
semaine de travail ça tempère les envies
c'est sûr et puis il ya aussi ceux qui
travaillent le soir même du réveillon
une soirée exceptionnelle en charge de
travail
je travaille en boulangerie et je
restais pour le réveillon a travaillé
jusqu'à 19h30 ah oui mais après 9h30
après je rentre le nom de ma tâche
commence à 7h du courage il en faut
aussi dans un tout autre registre bien
sûr quand on est ado lorsque pour la
soirée du réveillon
au lieu de faire la fête avec ses
copains le programme c'est chez moi
mes parents mais pour d'autres le
réveillon c'est avec personne je vous
fais un petit peu à manger parce que tu
es tout seul une solitude qui n'empêche
pas de célébrer le passage à la nouvelle
année dans la bonne humeur
je suis tout seul mais j'admire les
jeunes qui veulent faire le réveillant
parce que j'aime les jeunes malgré mes
90 ans mais quand même je vais me faire
un bon chocolat avec 1 grâce à un
chocolat un croissant ou même une flûte
de champagne un bon foie gras des
réjouissances qui ne devrait pas suffire
à égayer les plus beaux dont ceux pour
qui vraiment la soirée du nouvel an
signifie comme d'habitude m'emmerder
[Musique]